I mean I'm finally new role somebody has
to tell me why America just made this
guy so famous this is Ken bone one of
the undecided voters who asked a
question at last Sunday's debate and
since then has become a folk hero why
why because after 15 months of this
campaign he's still too stupid to pick
Ellery over president [ __ ] grabber for
me the great sadness of this election is
knowing that even if trump doesn't
become president we live in a country
where half the people think he should be
now I would really like to ask mr. Ken
bone or any undecided voter as these
last 15 months rolled along there was no
breaking point for you Trump saying he
would kill the children of terrorists
with drone strikes physically throwing
out 12 million Mexicans banning all
Muslims giving Saudi Arabian nukes
running a scam University cheating
veterans at a charity money not paying
taxes picking Putin as his favorite
leader not being able to let go of a
feud for a whole week with a beauty
queen the impressions of the handicapped
nothing last November when Trump was
losing in Iowa he said in Iowa to Iowans
how stupid are the people of Iowa
[Applause]
and now he's leading in Iowa so I guess
he got his answer that's how stupid
Florida is a climate ravaged state full
of old people and they elected as
governor a climate change denier who
when he was a businessman over so the
largest Medicare fraud in history and
it's not just Republicans 5% of Bernie
supporters have switched allegiance to a
ventriloquist dummy named Gary Johnson
whose policy positions are almost
uniformly the exact opposite of Bernie's
and who when pressed to name a foreign
country said Brangelina when asked does
the earth go around the Sun or the Sun
around the earth a full quarter of
Americans said the Sun revolves around
the earth and the Earth revolves around
NASCAR
Americans know they live in the greatest
country but 35% can't name one branch of
government only 36% can name all three a
full 80 percent think Ramadan is those
noodles college kids eat seven years ago
I was on CNN and said I didn't think
Sarah Palin ever be President but quote
I wouldn't put anything past this stupid
country then we went to a break and when
we came back Wolf Blitzer said this so
people are already complaining that
you're calling the United States a
stupid country and giving you a chance
to clarify I don't need to clarify it is
I hate to sound like Donald Trump but I
predicted it I called it in people are
giving me a lot of credit folks
blowing up the world is something that
could actually happen if you don't think
so you haven't seen enough movies movies
always foresee the future flip phones in
Star Trek touch screens in Minority
Report iPads in 2001 a Space Odyssey
black presidents before Obama
spectacular terrorist attacks on
American soil before 9/11 Network in
1976 predicted Fox News and reality TV
and Blade Runner showed a future Los
Angeles where life is bleak overcrowded
and dehumanizing and that's just on the
405
and of course Forrest Gump came out in
1994 years before we elected George W
Bush
and what scenario what scenario has
Hollywood
what does Hollywood been envisioning
lately I'm making a serious point for
Earth after an apocalypse Hunger Games
divergent Mad Max V for Vendetta Maze
Runner matrix interstellar the postman
the Book of Eli the road even little
Wally and how did earth reach this point
in these movies always because we did it
to ourselves in The Day the Earth Stood
Still Keanu Reeves plays an alien sent
to earth to exterminate mankind because
stupid selfish humans are destroying a
perfectly good planet he gets talked out
of it but it's not like he didn't have a
point in
[Applause]
in half of these movies it starts with
after humanity destroyed itself in the
great war what was left of government
decided human passions needed to be
controlled controlled by Kate Winslet in
divergent Julianne Moore in Hunger Games
Jodie Foster in Elysium Tilda Swinton in
snowpiercer
Meryl Streep in The Giver who says quote
when people have the freedom to choose
they choose wrong I know that makes her
the bad guy but did you watch the
Republican primaries I think I'm with
Meryl on this one if it's between
letting these people decide things or a
cold technocratic boss lady in a
pantsuit I'll take the lady in the pants
[Applause]